wow they're like some form of
genetically perfect super humans
very nice family our kids are gonna be
gorgeous
don't you think you should the parents
are wait does she think the parents are
good looking the parents look like
just normal people what was that
oh no he probably didn't go on the ski
trip either
don't you have magic ear powers to get
you out of this is it anderson
cooper what's he wearing
pajama bottoms
[Music]
look at that stud muffin look at that 23
year old high schooler this one is for
the top lock this one is for the bottom
what you're not gonna do it yourself
why not you did such a good job all
night
that was different those were strangers
all the more reason this should be even
easier for it's not even a
remote chance that would be breaking or
entering
i know what you're trying to do you
expect me to go in there and take one
look at my house and then i'll start
thinking about my family get all
touching
and then not want to go i'm sorry what
was the plot of this movie
it made santa looked better but i
thought it was for santa for
mrs claus to like him but they kind of
skipped that whole premise of the mrs
claus thing
and then the mall thing really never
amounted to anything because of the
phone call
so really nothing has happened in this
movie she hasn't learned a lesson
she's still a crazy she's still a
privileged [ __ ]
santa claus is the same dude you said he
lost some weight and was george hamilton
now for some reason
the mom has big tits i mean the security
guard didn't really do anything what
happened to the age security guard i
don't understand
so nothing has happened in this movie
nothing was learned
no lessons happened nothing happened
oh and hamburgers were thrown
oh that's right you have a sister
[Music]
oh and she looks 30 you're right hey
the kid looks older than the mom yeah
santa asked me to put your gift under
the tree
you're my gift under the tree what are
you why
i told santa i wanted you home for
christmas
but she was always gonna be home for
christmas she never went to the [ __ ]
she never went to the ski trip she was
always gonna be home for christmas
so this doesn't even make any sense it
would make sense if she was actually
going on the ski trip
and then came home for christmas anyway
but what was this
i don't even underst don't all this
marine stop it
maureen you watch all this [ __ ] you're
the reason this [ __ ] gets made
stop calling this there's no odds in
this
this is terrible i know you're doing it
to [ __ ] with me
but stop
they did they showed the [ __ ] boy
earlier he was with his pajamas
remember that guy anderson cooper
so had a good time
dealing with a teenage girl you sick
twisted man
you better watch 23 year old girl you're
talking to santa claus
little chucky lumly can it freak show
right now the goods are probably on a
ship to honduras
little black market toy ring huh the
only boy who was never on santa's list
no matter how much i wanted him to be
the chuck wagon don't care about santa's
list
and you want to know why cause santa
claus
doesn't exist but i do exist
and i got a list of my own and you're
both on it
it's a little something i like to call
banned
from the mall for life then if you could
do that at any point what was the point
of the contract and also
is getting pelted by the hamburger crew
yo let's still be cracking dog
thank you dog oh it's so good thanks for
hooking me up with the burgers i got
your back claws
yo guys this one's got captured please
alison
[Music]
i'm sorry i'm sorry that sleepy kraken
dog
are you [ __ ] serious right now so
they
just fly
i need a screaming pillow i swear to god
please
comet shall we go
everything is not tying up nicely stop
being sarcastic you [ __ ]
i know i did this to myself but stop
even pretending that this is
decent in any way
so did she ever all a good night marry
the hunker what happened
hey lins hey what's up hey were you in
my house last night
i uh got your note
i'm sorry what you
didn't get one of my friends to plan a
note in my stocking
uh no
what's it say is she nagging him
dear anderson if you're willing to skip
the ski trip you can come and watch
a movie with me and my family on
christmas day
i know i've been rude and since what
about your family don't you have a
family to spend on christmas day getting
my feelings
it also said something about how you
care way too much about clothes
love lindsay i don't write that
why are you yelling okay i guess the
joke's on me man i'm sorry
wait what
uh what i mean is
i didn't write it by myself
a friend helped me
how many shirts does he need
how many shirts does this gentleman need
i like you too okay but you gotta help
me out
because i can't spend
that's not adam from workaholics
lucy i'm home
so was mrs claus gotta makeover too
she a hot babe oh she is a hot babe
is that really you i might ask the same
question of you
mrs claus also got a makeover oh my
gosh she got her snatch typing each
other the same gift
matching christmas makeovers
aren't we just the cutest couple ever
what a [ __ ]
terrible movie i mean i have watched
some stinkers
since i've started doing this but
generic santa baby song generic
generic santa baby song royalty free
santa baby song
[Music]
this was a [ __ ] terrible
terrible movie whoa look at that
i would have given 500 but you made me
watch this
congrats on 500. thank you miami milf
you [ __ ] thank you so much
50 bucks that's very very sweet of you
uh
thank you everybody this was just a pile
of
[ __ ]
this is just a [ __ ] pile of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
well i hope you enjoyed this pile of
[ __ ] i enjoyed doing i enjoyed talking
over this bottle of [ __ ]
and don't worry we got some more we got
some more hallmark and lifetime movies
coming and
this month i'm going to try to do
christmas movies so just so you know
it's what's going to be happening all
right